You couldn't possibly have hated Oscar
Isaac's prosthetics for X-Men apocalypse
more than him his costume was so painful
he could barely even talk meanwhile
Colin Farrell's transformation for the
Batman was so complete you wouldn't
recognize him even his co-stars thought
he was just some scary guy on set these
are the best and worst movie Prosthetics
first up in the category of worst we
have Oscar Isaac's Prosthetics from
X-Men this look was just so big and
bulky it overshadowed the entire
performance even Oscar admitted
apocalypse that was excruciating and it
was mostly because of the costume
apparently Oscar hadn't realized that he
was going to be encased in glue latex
and a 40-pound suit for the role when he
signed on plus he had to sit on a
specially designed saddle and be rolled
into cooling tents between takes and so
I just wouldn't ever talk to anybody and
I was just going to be sitting and I
couldn't really move not only could he
barely move but he could barely speak
either the squeaking of the rubber and
plastic on his suit meant that
everything needed to be redubbed later
you can really see Oscar's discomfort
with his costume although uncomfortable
costumes don't always spell the death of
a performance Brendan Fraser didn't have
the easiest time with his Prosthetics in
the whale he had to wear a full suit
that weighed about 200 pounds heavy
enough that when he took it off at the
end of the day he felt completely
unsteady but that being said Brendan
took it all in stride it was
appropriately cumbersome should be he
even said that the Prosthetics helped
him to develop a better sense of who his
character is live the role let him be a
man it definitely looks like this could
be a real man and speaks to prosthetic
designer Adrian moreau's desire to give
us something with more finesse than
anything we've seen in movies before now
if morels this good at turning Brendan
into a 600 pound man we wonder if he
would have better luck transforming Guy
Pierce into a 105 four-year-old Guy
Pierce thought it was so cool being in
the alien movies it wasn't so cool
having to wear five hours of old age
prosthetic makeup this makeup looks
simply awful making guy look like a
raisin apparently Ridley Scott
originally planned on having moments
where guy would appear young without
Prosthetics but when those scenes were
written out even guy admits they could
have just cast a hundred year old guy
guy was also forced to wear a sort of
metal exoskeleton which meant I couldn't
sit down properly I said I just did this
and go let me know when you're ready
okay if you want to avoid waiting around
for our next video then we'd recommend
hitting that subscribe button but the
waiting wasn't even the worst part for
guy what was more difficult was the hour
that it took to get the microphob well
hey at least she wasn't almost kicked
off set
now this makeup was almost too good the
first time Colin Farrell did his full
makeup test for the penguin he was so
completely transformed that makeup
designer Mike Marino said nobody'd look
at him they thought who is this scary
guy on set Colin said hi to Jeffrey
Wright and he looked at me like he
wanted me thrown off the set but it all
worked out at the end of the day and
then he went over and I saw him talk to
the director and the director pointed
back over here and then he came back he
was like Colin the entire cast was
amazed by just how real
real wanted it took him about four hours
to apply all those prosthetic pieces
although they managed to get it down to
about an hour and a half with practice
Mourinho tried to keep the silicone
layers pretty thin so that Colin would
still be able to act through them a
problem Christopher Eccleston knows well
now Christopher feels like Marvel lied
to him when he was approached to play
malekith he was told that there would be
a little bit of Prosthetics and then
there was seven hours of prosthetics
which is a lot more than a little bit it
may have been worth it if only
Christopher were still able to act
through heavy makeup it was just so
overpowering resulting in a flat
performance that even Christopher would
admit was not my finest moment
surprisingly enough the part that he was
most upset about was his contact lenses
which he felt made it difficult for him
to connect with the audience an obstacle
between the audience and your eyes is is
questionable but considering even he
admits that he's made contact lenses
work for him before we aren't sure we
blame this one on the eyes but maybe he
should have taken a page from Jared
Leto's page and have his makeup done
offset Al Pacino knows a little
something about what Jeffrey Wright went
through Jared Leto would arrange to have
his makeup done separate from the house
of Gucci set so that he'd show up to
work completely in character in fact the
first time that Jared met Al who plays
his father in the film he came up to him
like it's me Paulo but there was only
one problem Jared's Prosthetics were so
convincing L had no no idea who this
crazy guy was and he basically shuffled
off against like who's this this creep
fortunately someone was around to
whisper to poor confused ow
Jared and he turned around he said oh my
son
this look is especially impressive when
you consider that the Prosthetics
designer only had three weeks to put it
all together and it still wound up
looking better than Leonardo DiCaprio's
Prosthetics in J Edgar so here's a
little tip for filmmakers if you're
going to use Prosthetics it's probably
best to keep using them Leonardo
DiCaprio had to be aged up using
prosthetics for the movie J Edgar but
the fact that they kept jumping back and
forth between Leo's natural face when he
was younger and the Prosthetics when he
was older made them all the more
distracting Leo had his longtime makeup
artist Sean work on this look and even
though Leo's been subjected to some very
long makeups by him in the past even
sean would admit that this film is his
most challenging the more pieces of
silicone piled onto his face the more
Leo started to feel claustrophobic and
although he tried to use that for the
character there was just no getting
around the fact that this was just a bad
look and we don't mean that in the way
that the baron from Dune is bad to play
the baron Stalin Skarsgard had to be
physically in intimidating I wanted to
feel a menace of that massive human
being and that weight in total Stellan
wound up spending around 80 hours in the
makeup trailer being outfitted in a suit
that required seven sculptors and
consisted of at least nine separate
pieces for his face head neck and other
body parts this wasn't an easy process
for stellen physically uh you have to
sit still straight for seven hours but
it was all worth it in the end to just
see how effective the Prosthetics were
in turning the baron into a threat still
that doesn't mean that there weren't
issues with the Prosthetics on set
especially when it came to the neck
which with its massive weights of 25
pounds had a tendency to buckle if the
crew wasn't watching it close enough but
at least Stalin can still act through
his facial Prosthetics which is more
than we can say for Hugo weaving did you
ever notice when Hugo weaving was recast
in Avengers Infinity War we bet you
didn't because these Prosthetics were
completely overwhelming that permanent
scowl made impossible for Hugo to act
through them though interestingly enough
that wasn't the reason he decided not to
come back for the sequels that had more
to do with disagreements over money
although Hugo had no problem sitting for
several hours a day for the makeup
process which was made up of seven
distinct silicone pieces Hugo even
looked back on the process of filming
Captain America the First Avenger as a
lot of fun and we're glad to hear that
he enjoyed the makeup more than
Christopher did it just overpowers the
characters so much that it's the only
thing you remember about Red Skull which
is a really bad sign especially when you
see entries like our next one where the
Prosthetics are more about informing the
character than hiding her Jessica
Chastain was completely transformed into
Tammy Faye Baker she had to wear a
series of Prosthetics in three separate
stages that would allow her character to
age throughout the course of the film it
began with Jessica wearing little more
than silicone cheeks and a silicone chin
as well as invisible tape at the end of
her nose to make her face look a little
bit more like the famous televangelists
but by the end there had been a lot more
than that I think the longest day that I
was in Prosthetics was seven hours
obviously this wasn't easy on Jessica
which really starts to make you feel
like you're you're about to go crazy
you're about to go nuts but it went a
long way towards making her completely
unrecognizable in this role alongside
her Andrew Garfield had also been
transformed into Tammy's husband Jim and
the special effects makeup artist drew
influence from real Archives of the
couple so as to make sure he got every
detail right between the long hours and
the heavy Prosthetics these actors
certainly put themselves through a lot
for our entertainment which one of these
movie Transformations were you the most
surprised by and are there any other
samples that we might have missed make
sure to let us know down in the comment
section
foreign